aux chers collègues l'ordre du jour
appelle la question orale de Monsieur
Gérard César à madame la garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
le ministre mes chers collègues ma
question pose et pose le problème de la
situation du centre pénitentiaire de
Bordeaux Gradignan en Gironde
cette maison d'arrêt centre
pénitentiaire a été bâtie en 1967
et elle a plus de 45 ans initialement
prévue pour accueillir 448 tenus un
accueille aujourd'hui près de 700 pour
un taux d'occupation de 155%
. ce centre pénitentiel a toujours dit
le plus surpeuplé de l'intérêt région
suite à deux visites effectuées dans
cette maison d'arrêt en date du 16
octobre 2008 et du 14 janvier 2009 la
Commission consultative départementale
sécurité a émis un avis défavorable à la
poursuite sur l'exploitation c'est un
non conformité il a vétusté importante
des bâtiments inciter votre prédécesseur
a décidé de la fermeture de ce centre et
d'engager la construction d'un nouvel
établissement sur le site existant sa
capacité d'accueil devait être de 589
places donc 491 40 femmes 30 mineurs 24
quartiers accueillent évaluation quel
service médico-psychiatrique plus 82
quartiers de semis liberté
pour améliorer nettement la qualité de
vie des détenus et permettre de
meilleures conditions de travail
personnel pénitentiaires le projet
prévoyait un enseignement individuel
garantit à 95%, ainsi que des quartiers
d'hébergement dimensionner la taille
humaine et de plus de lumière naturelle
il prévoyait également une augmentation
des surfaces pour offrir des tenues plus
d'activités socioculturelle sportive
scolaires et professionnel de même il
devait favoriser l'accueil des familles
des détenus et s'insérer parfaitement
dans le site et l'environnement
madame la gardeesseau la poursuite de ce
projet n'a pas figuré dans vos priorités
pour le plan triennal de rénovation des
prisons en cours actuellement depuis
2010 la municipalité de Gradignan
travaille sur ce projet avec le service
construction de votre ministère à la
fois pour le compatible le PLU de la
Communauté urbaine de Bordeaux et pour
favoriser l'abaissement des bâtiments et
la végétalisation du site voilà
plusieurs mois que les responsables
syndicaux du site se plaignent
d'agression est dénonce des conditions
de travail particulièrement difficiles
tout en constatant de très mauvaises
conditions de prise en charge des tenues
dans des cellules insalubre inadaptées à
l'accueil de deux voire trois personnes
malgré la qualité du travail de
l'engagement de la direction et de
l'ensemble des personnels
œuvrant sur le site la mise en place de
conditions satisfaisantes de l'insertion
reste difficile et préoccupante la
construction de nouvelles établissement
est indispensable dans les meilleures
délais à conséquence madame le
gardeesseau je vous demande de confirmer
l'inscription de la reconstruction du
centre pénitentiaire de Bordeaux
gatrignan au plan triennal 2016 2018 de
rénovation des prisons merci la parole
était Madame Christiane Taubira garde
des somnis de la justice
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur vous avez raison de rendre
hommage à nos personnels de nos
établissements pénitentiaires et de
Bordeaux Gradignan Draguignan en
particulier parce qu'effectivement ils
ont le sens du service public et au
quotidien ils assurent un service de
qualité dans des conditions de travail
qui ne sont pas toujours satisfaisantes
même si nous nous employons
quotidiennement à tenter de les
améliorer concernant l'établissement
effectivement vous avez raison 150 moi
j'ai 150 mais 155% nous n'allons pas
chipoter c'est trop c'est de la
surpopulation carcérale donc c'est une
situation qui n'est pas satisfaisante
vous savez que nous avons entrepris des
travaux des travaux cette année 2013
pour 500.000 euros qui ont concerné une
remise aux normes électriques une
consolidation des cuisines des enfumage
des cellules du quartier disciplinaire
par ailleurs vous savez que j'ai décidé
d'un plan de sécurisation de nos
établissements et dans le cadre de ce
plan de sécurisation cet établissement
bénéficiera d'un million de travaux
réservés
strictement à la sécurisation de
l'établissement pour le reste j'entends
votre demande de construction de notre
nouvel établissement vous savez
effectivement que la la fermeture est
donc le remplacement de cet
établissement n'a pas été retenu dans le
triennage sur lequel nous sommes encore
puisque de toute façon le budget de la
justice est passé devant le Parlement
par contre j'entends effectivement la
situation dégradée encore que le
quartier de Penza ménagé soit un
quartier qui n'a été ouvert d'ailleurs
qu'en 2011 et qui en bon état mais les
deux autres établissements effectivement
sont de sont fortement dégradés
je ne nous avons des contraintes
budgétaires qui font que effectivement
au niveau des priorités de ce trial je
n'ai pas retenu cette établissement il
fera partie des examens prioritaires du
prochain triennal d'ailleurs à preuve de
cet engagement qui n'est pas un
engagement
désinvolte je n'en fais jamais
d'ailleurs je n'en prends jamais
apprendre de cet engagement j'ai demandé
que l'on prenne des dispositions
concernant un terrain parce que dans
l'hypothèse où je pourrais retenir
effectivement la construction de cet
établissement qui effectivement avait
été prévu dans le passé mais en
partenariat public privé et sans que
toutes les études nécessaires étaient
effectuées dans l'hypothèse où je
pourrais retenir ce le remplacement de
cet établissement je fais déjà étudié
l'emprise sur le terrain
vous le savez je suppose en tout cas si
vous ne savez pas je vous fais parvenir
toutes les informations nécessaires et
bien entendu je ne manquerai pas de vous
tenir informé de l'évolution des choses
et je veillerai à ce que aussi bien la
pige que l'administration pénitentiaire
vous communique les informations au fur
et à mesure qu'elles viendront à notre
disposition merci Monsieur César
oui merci Madame le Ministre j'ai bien
noté vos observations et aussi les
enveloppes travaux qui sont prioritaires
par rapport à la vétusté de cette
établissement
tout à l'heure notre collègue Jacques
mesard j'ai bien entendu votre réponse
vous avez dit que vous étiez prêt à
organiser une réunion de travail pour la
prison de Rouillac ce que je souhaite
madame le ministre si vous étiez
d'accord c'est qu'on puisse mettre un
gros travail similaire pour la prison de
Bordeaux Gradignan ça me paraît
indispensable de le faire parce que
vraiment 155% donc de taux d'occupation
c'était énorme et les détenus ne sont
pas aujourd'hui
logés comme il devrait être logé malgré
le tout le travail qui est fait par les
surveillants et la direction
pénitentiaire donc peut-être cette
réunion de travail madame ministre était
d'accord nous pourrions l'organiser dans
les prochains jours avec bien sûr tous
nos partenaires qui seraient invités à
cette réunion merci Madame
merci mon cher collègue